Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 is
officially live and now that the
multiplayer is being enjoyed by the
masses we know some of its shortcomings
let's start with the cross play issue
games with cross-play support generally
offer the ability to toggle it on and
off since some console players might not
want to play with PC players on mouse
and keyboard and some PC players would
prefer not to play with console players
that have aim assist however for some
unknown reason the option to turn off
cross play in Modern Warfare 2 is only
available to the PS4 and PS5 players
meaning Xbox and PC players are stuck
being lumped into cross-play lobbies
unless developer Infinity Ward makes a
change and for some this may not be
surprising at all given the option to
turn off cross play was also omitted
from titles such as Call of Duty Warzone
and Halo infinite Xbox players do have
the ability to circumvent this Omission
at a system level toggling off support
for crossplay that will apply to all
games on the system I'll leave the steps
for doing so in the description now
let's talk about the border crossing map
Santa sent a border crossing places
players on a highway packed with an
unthinkable amount of cars most Maps
feature a square or rectangle layout but
the border crossing is a very narrow and
linear map with very little escape from
the cars there are a few buildings just
outside the highway but the map leaves
much to be desired in terms of variety
and cover most of the fighting takes
place with nothing but the traffic jam
of cars many of which will explode from
damage one grenade or killstreak can set
off a chain reaction of exploding cars
and there's a little chance of surviving
once they start igniting some players
have even taken to social media to call
it the Piccadilly of Modern Warfare 2.
as Piccadilly was a modern warfare 2019
map that also received a lot of talk and
negative attention over its design
personally I loved Piccadilly and after
playing two matches on border crossing I
gotta say I don't hate it now one of
those matches I came in Midway and all
of the cars had kind of exploded already
but the second one I was there from the
beginning and it just the cars didn't
seem to really get in my way or kill me
a bunch it wasn't that bad it was cool
it was fine it was fine and I'm not the
only one that doesn't hate it some users
were praising how the map played in no
spawn Search and Destroy mode another
user suggests the map would actually be
okay if the cars didn't explode players
who took part in the beta might also
notice one map is missing from Modern
Warfare 2's launch lineup valdera's
Museum was playable during the
multiplayer open Beta but has been
removed from the final game which is
kind of a huge bummer because that was
my favorite map from the beta so fingers
crossed that it shows up in the future
and let's end this Friday with a bit of
an odd story Activision and Burger King
partnered to give Whopper eaters an
exclusive operator skin based on Burger
Town a fictional restaurant in the Call
of Duty Universe the Cosmetic bundle
comes with a burger Town t-shirt for
your character along with one hour of
Double XP the promotion is available in
numerous places around the world but
apparently not in the United States
however the codes seemingly aren't
region locked so anyone who obtains a
code by any means can use it auction
site eBay is full of listings for the
Burger King DLC in fact one seller has
already sold more than 200 of them with
the asking price sitting at forty
dollars USD and there are plenty of
others too I hate to be the one to say
this but if I was at Activision and I
was I was just like one of the big head
people there or something I would look
at this situation and go wow if they're
willing to pay 40 bucks for a digital
in-game t-shirt that's not even like
super super rare and limited and
whatever like just go to a different
country and buy a Whopper boom you have
this shirt
maybe they'll be willing to buy nft
skins in Call of Duty so stop it
don't buy any more of those codes off
eBay stop it but that's it for me I'm
out of here I'm gonna go play some more
Call of Duty and enjoy my weekend you do
the same or play whatever you're really
into and I will see you in the next one
thank you
foreign